Film Courage: What if a writer does not
know if they're a conceptual
writer or an intuitive writer?
Corey Mandell, Screenwriter and Screenwriting
Instructor: Yeah great question. I can tell
in 10 seconds but I've been doing this a while so
what I'll do is well I can tell by reading it but
that's not going to be helpful to the writer the
writer can't necessarily read it but here's what
a writer can do so I'll ask a writer question so
I can tell from a writer and I haven't read their
writing so what I'll do is now they have to have
written at least a script so I'll say let's talk
about the last script you why did you write it
what was your inspiration what was your jumping
off point what did you get excited about I just
listen and I can tell in 10 seconds so if it's a
conceptual writer first of all they're going to
be answering from just their voice it's going to
be answering from the more analytical intellectual
part of the brain that then you just can hear that
but also they're going to be talking about they
started with an idea a concept o no one's done
a thriller where or this I thought would be a
really good comedy or they'll talk about oh a
twist ending they had or an opening story stuff
or they might be talking about world conceptual
writers love world building so could be world
building could be a concept an idea part of
a story a beginning a twist ending a this a con
that's now when you when you talk to an intuitive
writer they're going to be talking about it
from a more emotionally authentic vulnerable
place and they're almost always going to say well
so there's this character and it's a character or
or it's something personal and they might be able
to say like I worked with a writer once and she's
like I just went through this really painful
divorce and I either just cry myself to sleep
every night and drink or I could write about it
okay so that's an intuitive writer or sometimes
they don't even know they'll say I don't know
and they're almost embarrassed but like I had
to write this I just had to write this that's an
intuitive writer so what is your inspiration what
got you excited another thing I'll ask is okay so
when you're working on this script was there ever
a point where you got in a like it got tough
like you got lost or you you you didn't know
what to do and they're oh yeah yeah I go what did
you do and an intuitive writer they they're going
to find the solution in the character and just
what feels right and the conceptual writer is
like well I thought for the someone who reads
it' be good if this happens and they're just
coming at it from a completely different space
not just to confuse this for a moment I always
get in my workshops I get I'd say 90% of the
writers within a few weeks they know they're
conceptual or intuitive and there's no gender
to this I mean I have equal amount of conceptual
writers or men and women same with intuitive
but there's always like one or two or three
writers who will say I'm so confused I really
thought I was intuitive because this but then
I thought I was conceptual when I do this sees I
feel like I'm both but I don't think I do either
that great exactly there's a small percentage of
writers I call them slidable so if you think about
like the conceptual and the intuitive and most
people obviously unless you've had like brain
damage you have access to both parts and you use
different parts when you sleep you're using your
intuitive when you're solving math you're doing
the conceptual but most people will hang out here
as a writer or hang out here but there's some
small percent of writers that just slide back
and forth back and forth so they're like oh yeah
I thought I was no I thought it was this and they
they're like kind of equally comfortable they just
slide back and forth but they're not strong enough
in either space so they will just pick one space
stay there get really strong at it then go over
here and get really strong at this if you are
slidable you should celebrate because that's
the hardest part so I'm I'm a DieHard conceptual
writer so when I was doing this training it was
so hard to turn off the conceptual brain it was
so hard to go over here and when I was over here
at some point I'd have a conceptual thought or
conceptual concern I just goop and I would just
stay here I had to learn how to slide back and
forth effortlessly that's the hardest thing for
me to teach someone and some people naturally do
it I don't know why but they do so it's possible
someone listening to this they answer the
questions that I asked and they're like I
kind of think I'm both that is possible but you
might need to get stronger at one or both sides.